[MUSIC PLAYING]
MAGNUS NILSSON: So first of all,
thank you all for coming today,
and thanks for having
me again at Google.
It's always very
nice to be here.
So I've written a few books now.
And this latest one--
"The Nordic Baking
Book"-- it actually marks
the end to a six
year research process
that's produced "The Nordic
Cookbook" after three years
and now finishes with
this publication.
And the whole purpose of these
books were to be documentary
and to tell people about Nordic
food culture in a true way.
Because I think that
Nordic food culture
is one of the most misunderstood
food cultures on the planet.
I mean, largely because of
people like myself, actually.
Because if you search on
the internet for Nordic food
culture, Nordic cooking,
things like that,
the first thing you get up is
1,000 articles about Faviken,
and Noma, and a handful of other
very ambitious contemporary
restaurants.
And none of them really are
very indicative of how people
actually eat in the Nordics.
And then, aside
of that, you also
get a whole bunch of recipes
for gravlax, for herring,
and for meatballs,
and cinnamon buns.
And those are Nordic dishes,
but that's not really
what people eat on an
everyday basis either.
And then the last
thing you get is
a lot of people photographing
their meatball meal at Ikea.
So I felt that there was a
real need for these books.
And it's been an
enormous privilege
to get to spend this long--
supported by a publisher--
researching my own food culture.
A food culture that I
thought I knew a lot about,
and that it turned out that
I knew a lot less than I
thought about.
And it's a little bit strange
now to see both books out,
the project being done.
But it's also amazing to see
people interact with both
of the books, tagging me
in photos on social media,
or buns they've made.
People coming to these
lectures and really
learning about the food
culture that I think they
knew very little about before.
And one thing that I
learned, especially
during the second
half of this project,
is how great the
diversity and the depth
is of Nordic baking culture.
And I've come to believe very
firmly that Nordic baking
culture is actually
the greatest baking
culture on the planet today in
terms of diversity and depth.
And that might sound
a little bit less
than obvious for most people.
And my plan now is that I'm
going to spend the next 30
minutes or so talking
about, making my case
for Nordic baking culture.
And then I'll open up for
some question towards the end.
Do we have a problem?
Sorry, Justin.
JUSTIN: No, it's OK.
Go ahead.
I got this.
MAGNUS NILSSON: Justin.
So the best place to start
when we talk about culture,
it's the people.
Because without people, we
can't have any culture--
baking or otherwise.
And the Nordic
region, it's inhabited
by about 26 million people.
And they're spread out
over a surface area
just under 3.5 million
square kilometers.
That can't, by any stretch,
be called particularly densely
populated.
We can compare this to,
for example, the whole rest
of Europe--
without the Nordics--
which would then
have about 90 people
per square kilometer.
Gets even more interesting
if you start comparing
to specific countries.
Let's say France, for example.
France has 116 people
per square kilometer.
Germany-- the most populous
country in Europe--
has 237 people per
square kilometer.
And as a little example--
to compare the two--
if you were to take
all of the Germans
and you spread them
out in an even layer
across their whole
country, you would end up
having a German every 75
meter in every direction.
One even layer.
If you were to do the
same in the Nordic region,
there would be 375 meters
between each person.
That's a huge difference.
So we have this vast
geographical area
with a very, very
scarce population.
And if we were to
go back in time,
let's say a few hundred
years to an era when
a lot of what we consider our
cultural identity of today
was actually founded, what would
this scarcity of population
actually have meant for the way
that knowledge was transmitted
between people?
Can anyone give me
some examples perhaps?
What do you think?
What would this mean?
Think before social media,
television, cell phones,
all of this stuff.
AUDIENCE: Not a lot of
[INAUDIBLE] recipes.
MAGNUS NILSSON: Anyone else?
AUDIENCE: A lot
of word of mouth.
MAGNUS NILSSON: A
lot of word of mouth.
I think that the most
important general observation
about the difference
between now and then
would be that information
knowledge everywhere
would have been transmitted at
a much slower pace back than it
is now.
And, as you say, word of mouth.
You essentially had to talk
face-to-face to a person
to acquire the information
that they might have.
Or you had to write a letter.
And I think that we
can all agree that
writing a physical letter--
although it's a
beautiful thing--
is not a particularly
efficient way
of sharing lots of
information quickly.
Or the third option--
if you wanted
to learn from a trusted source--
you could also read a book.
And back then, 300 years ago,
there were like three books.
One was the Bible,
and then there
were two more that didn't
deal with baking either.
So none of these things would
have actually really done much
for the culture of baking.
So if we were to agree, then,
that information flowed slower
everywhere because of
the lack of technology,
I think we can also imagine
that in an area as scarcely
populated as the Nordic region,
this effect would have been
further exaggerated simply
because there is just much more
distance between
each person that you
can interact with face-to-face.
And this is very important
for my reasoning,
and it's something that I
will come back to a little bit
later.
Now, I'm going to
make an example
as well to illustrate this.
So I have my good friend
Johan on here tonight.
He sits there in the back.
He happened to be in
San Francisco today,
so he just came here
to have a look as well.
And let's say that
Johan tomorrow
would invent a new cake recipe.
And it's not just
any cake recipe.
It's actually the most delicious
cake recipe ever invented
by humankind.
It's completely revolutionary.
And he would bake
this cake recipe.
Maybe he would share
it with his family.
And he would do what
most people do today
when they do something
they're proud of,
some kind of achievement.
He would share it
on social media.
And because of this cake and
its extreme deliciousness,
everyone who sees it on social
media, they're a bit excited.
Because he's claiming that he's
made the world's best cake,
right?
And perhaps a few of them
will ask for the recipe,
and they will do the same thing.
They will also bake it.
And little by little,
information generation
by information generation,
this cake recipe
spreads out into the world.
And then all of a
sudden, maybe it
hits someone with a bit more
reach, perhaps a couple 100,000
followers.
And it gets even further out
into the world of information.
And all of a sudden, it's
featured on "Martha Stewart
Living," Johan's cake recipe.
And then it takes one more week,
and it's my birthday back home
in Sweden.
And Tove, my wife--
who has also done a lot
of the recipe development
for these two books--
she's made a birthday cake.
But it's not my
normal birthday cake,
which is the green
marzipan layer
cake, which is the
princess cake, the most
delicious birthday
cake there is, I think.
No, no.
It's another one.
It's a new one.
But it's not
Johan's cake either.
It's the vegan, raw food
version of Johan's cake
that Tove's gotten from
her goop newsletter.
And that's how information flows
today when it comes to food.
Much, much faster.
And not only does it spread
more quickly over a large area,
it also mutates quicker
into new versions of itself.
And this is a huge difference.
This hasn't been going
on for very long.
And if we were to compare
this with how things were back
a couple of hundred
years ago, Johan
could still have
invented the cake.
It would have been equally
delicious as it was today.
He would have made
it for his family.
And then that would
have been it, right?
And then perhaps
when Johan's kids
were to leave the house after
20 years of eating his cake,
perhaps they got married
into the neighboring
farm 800 meters away,
another four people
would have learned
about the cake.
So in the span of
20 years, it would
have spread over a
diameter of 2 kilometers,
and eight people
would have known
about the cake, the most
delicious cake invented
by humankind.
And this is a bit of
an over exaggeration,
but I think that
you get the point.
And to put this simply,
a scarce population
spread out over a vast
area used to mean--
and to some extent
still means today--
that knowledge travels slower.
And this, in its
turn, it will always
mean that you get a more varied
expression of all commonly
practiced culture.
This is simply because
people are less
influenced by each other because
they do less of the same stuff.
And this is one reason to
why the Nordic region has
a more diverse baking
culture than almost
any other region in the world.
Another reason
for this diversity
that is also somewhat related
to the scarcity of population--
and which really influences
the baking culture-- it's
the bakeries and
their role in society.
And in the Nordics,
baking culture,
it's not carried primarily
by commercial bakeries,
but rather by people
in their homes.
And this is not just
something that used
to be accurate in the past.
It's also something that
still applies today.
And this has to
do with geography.
Because what does bakeries
need to sustain themselves?
AUDIENCE: Customers.
MAGNUS NILSSON: Customers.
Exactly.
They're going to need
to have people there.
And if you have 375 meters to
every person, that's not many.
And there are definitely
bakeries in the Nordics.
There's always been
But they're
concentrated in quite
a small geographical area.
At least they used
to be historically.
You would have found most
of these bakeries that
were common enough
to produce bread
as a daily staple in cities.
And most of the
cities in the Nordics
are in the southern
third of Sweden,
a bit on the southwest coast
of Finland, all of Denmark,
and then an area around
Oslo, and a little bit
up on the west coast of Norway.
That's where you
would have found
these cities that were big
enough to sustain bakeries
in the past.
And I actually did
a little test when
I did another talk that was on
a completely different subject I
guess some weeks ago.
I had 100 people in the
room, and I asked them
all what they thought
was the greatest baking
culture on the planet.
None of them said Nordic.
What do you guys
think they said?
AUDIENCE: France.
MAGNUS NILSSON: Yeah.
They said France.
Or 99 of them said
France, and then there
was this one guy
who said Austrian.
And I started
thinking about this.
And I think that
I would have said
in France as well before
starting with this project.
And I started
thinking more about
why does everyone think this?
What's the substance behind
this immediate assumption
from almost every
person you meet
that the French baking culture
is the greatest on the planet?
I think that this simply
a case and a great example
of a very, very clever
and successfully executed
branding exercise by the French.
You visit France.
There's baguettes, you buy them.
There are eclairs, you buy them.
And then you have a
great time in France.
And if we start to look at what
French baking culture actually
is, it's the polar opposite
to what Nordic baking culture
looks like.
Have I done something strange?
AUDIENCE: No.
MAGNUS NILSSON: Oh, good.
As opposed to ours, the
French baking culture
is almost entirely driven
by professional bakeries.
People in France, they don't
bake that much at home.
And I mean, why would they?
There's a bakery in every
tiny little village in France.
And France is very evenly
and quite densely populated
as we said before.
So there is absolutely
no incentive
to bake your own bread
on a regular basis,
so that it becomes
a daily staple.
And if we take this a step
further, and think about what
this actually means
for the culture
of eating and baking bread.
I imagine that
many in this room--
perhaps almost all of you--
have been to France, and you
have bought and eaten something
from a French bakery.
Perhaps you were
there on vacation.
Perhaps you lived
there for a while.
I don't know.
But I think that most of us can
agree that French bakeries are
lovely places.
The baguettes, the butter
croissant, pain au chocolat,
apricot turnovers,
flan, pain croissant.
All of these things are examples
of great, great pastries
and bakes.
And I too love a French bakery.
I used to live there.
I've been to a lot of them.
And not just in Paris
where I lived, but all
over the country.
And when I started thinking
about these things, one thing
that I realized that they're
pretty much all the same.
They share almost exactly the
same repertoire of baked goods
regardless of where
in France they are.
And sure, the butter rolled
into a croissant in Brittany
might be a little bit saltier
than the one outside of Nice.
Perhaps the apricots
are fresh in the south,
and they're canned in the north.
And there are definitely
some regional variations
and some regional
specialties that
are added on to this standard
repertoire across the country.
But, all in all, they
are remarkably similar.
And as I said before, in France,
people rarely bake at home.
And if they do,
they bake dessert.
Might go to the bakery,
buy a roll of puff pastry,
and go home and
make tarte tatin.
That's sort of the extent of it.
And as you can understand,
this is not exactly
a great growing ground
for cultural individuality
and diversity.
And this is because businesses--
bakeries are businesses.
And businesses, they have
to function financially.
And this happens when you find
that sweet spot between what
people want to buy
and what's actually
possible to produce in an
efficient enough manner.
So there is always going to
be-- for all cultures dominated
by businesses--
certain circumstances
and rules around
them that will shape
and, to quite a large
degree, streamline
what these places produce.
And I think that very often with
food, we tend to forget this.
Because we are so--
we take food for granted.
And we don't really see food
as part of normal business,
even though it is, obviously.
And I think you can make a bit
of an interesting comparison
with, for example, other
types of manufacturing.
Let's say, that you compare
bakeries and car companies.
So almost all car
companies-- except
for some cosmetic
differences-- make
essentially the same product.
Rectangular box,
wheel in each corner,
it goes either like
that or like that.
They kind of do the same thing.
And the same rules apply there,
because they're a business.
And they collectively
figure out the best way
of producing something that's
as close as possible to what
people want to buy.
And it's exactly the
same for the bakeries.
And also, most bakeries,
they're run by bakers.
And most bakers
who run bakeries,
they've also gone to
school somewhere where
they learned how to bake.
Incidentally, they learned how
to bake exactly the same way
as pretty much all of the
others who also went to school
and started bakeries.
And because their
business model works
and has worked for a long
time, most likely what they're
going to teach the next
generation of bakers
is some iteration of what
they are already doing.
And none of this really
promotes diversity in culture.
So in a baking culture
driven by bakeries,
you will inevitably
only have a fraction
of the diversity found in
a culture that's driven
by people baking in the home.
And this is another reason why
there is no more diverse baking
culture in the world
than in the Nordics.
And I actually think that
a comparison between the US
and Sweden here
really illustrates
the differences in how much
people actually bake at home.
Because something that I've
understood here in the US
now when we've done
all of the recipe
testing with independent
recipe testers in America
to see that the recipes actually
function and also something
that I've come to talk a lot
about during this tour when
we're meeting people and
talking about the book
is that it's hard to
buy fresh yeast here.
Essentially, it seems
to me that if you
want to buy fresh
yeast in America,
you have to sort of sneak up
in the alley behind some bakery
and go in the back door and
buy some of their yeast stash.
Which is very different
from how it would be in,
for example, Sweden
where you can
buy fresh yeast in every grocery
store, every petrol station,
every 7-Eleven.
Many newsstands will
have fresh yeast.
That's not just
because they have
a pretty yellow color-- the
cubes-- and people have them
for fun.
It's because people buy them.
And people buy them because
they want to bake with them.
And I think that
this illustrates
how big a part of people's
home cooking baking
makes out in the Nordic region.
And then you have
geography and climate.
Another very important
influence on what people eat.
And as I said before, the
Nordics, it's a vast region.
From the southernmost
bits of Denmark,
all the way up to the
northern parts of Spitsbergen
islands, north of Norway.
From Finland in the
east to Greenland
all the way in the west.
It's a huge region.
You can fit all of
the rest of Europe
a whole bunch of times in there.
I think you can fit the whole
US in there as well easily.
And sure, a lot
of this is ocean.
But that doesn't really matter.
Because when it comes
to cultural diversity,
dependent on the geography,
the important thing
is not that it's
evenly populated.
The important thing is the
distance between the extremes
where people actually live.
And in terms of climate,
naturally, in such a vast area,
you will also have
a lot of variation.
And this, in its
turn, it will mean
what people have been
able to grow in the past
and thereby bake with and
integrate into our culture,
it's varied a lot depending
on where they live.
And you can think
wheat, for example.
Wheat is a grain that needs
fairly particular circumstances
to grow well.
It needs a long enough
and a warm enough summer.
It needs quite a lot of water.
And it needs very fertile
ground to grow well.
And these circumstances
you won't find everywhere
in the Nordic region.
You'll actually find them
pretty much in that same region
where all of those cities
are located funnily.
So in the southern
third of Sweden,
a little bit on the
Finnish west coast,
a little bit in South
Norway, and all over Denmark.
That's where wheat was
traditionally grown.
And it's also where most
of the wheat-based recipes
in traditional Nordic
baking happens to come from.
And funnily enough, what used
to be practical limitations
on necessities in the
past tends to inform
our choices today a lot.
And you can go on, you can
look at, for example, Denmark.
So Denmark has the most fertile
farmland in the Nordics.
It's a great agricultural
production area,
and they grow a lot of wheat.
And wheat has always been an
important trade commodity.
Very expensive.
So what they used
to do historically
is that they grew the
wheat on their best land,
and then they sold it off
to continental Europe.
Almost all of it.
And on all of the poorer pieces
of land, instead of wheat,
they grew rye.
Because rye, it
ripens very dependably
every summer in Denmark.
And they therefore have a
really great rye bread culture.
And because southern
Sweden is close to Denmark,
you'll also find a bit
of rye bread there.
And you'll find in both
Denmark and south Sweden breads
that you historically wouldn't
have found anywhere else, which
were breads that had both
rye and wheat in them.
Unique to this area.
And then you can
look at Finland.
So Finland has almost all rye.
Almost no other grains are used
in traditional Finnish baking.
And this is because
most of the country
is located too far north.
So it's too cool in the summer
for the wheat to grow there.
And then in the southern part,
the warmest part of Finland,
it has inland climates
towards the Russian border.
So even if it would have been
warm enough for the wheat
to grow there and the summer
would have been long enough,
it's too dry.
So it doesn't work.
But rye, it can take a lot
less water during the summer.
And it informs all of
their baking culture.
Where I grew up, further
north up in Sweden,
you can't grow wheat because
it's too cool in the summer.
You can't grow rye either
for the same reason.
So people used to
grow oats and barley.
And oats, it has no
gluten at all in it.
And barley will have a
little bit of gluten.
And gluten you need
to make fluffy breads.
So the further north you come
in Scandinavia, the flatter
the breads will be until you hit
the point, sort of halfway up
through Sweden and Norway--
where I used to grow up--
where the traditional
bakes would be only
flatbreads either soft or dry.
And I'm going to
compare this to France
again, just because it's a
very easy comparison to make.
So what grains do
we find in France?
It's wheat everywhere.
They grow almost
exclusively wheat.
Why would they
grow anything else?
Pretty much all of the
country-- except for the warmest
and driest bits
towards the southeast--
has a great growing
climate for wheat.
And wheat is, in Europe,
it has traditionally
been the most well
paid for grain crop.
But then you look at the
repertoire of recipes.
Almost all of the
recipes for both breads
and savory pastries
in France, they're
based on one single
grain, which is wheat.
If you look all
over the Nordics,
we've had four
different grains who've
all been equally important to
specific parts of the region.
Meaning that we have four
times as much base material
to work with.
Meaning more diversity.
We can do the
questions afterwards.
Sorry.
So these climate and
its limiting factors
has historically created
a lot of diversity.
And as I said before, the
Nordic region is also vast.
But it's a vast region that's
located almost all of it
in the marginal climates.
And it's marginal in the
sense that for people
to successfully
live there, you have
to plan ahead a little bit.
You can't just expect to
harvest plant-based foods
all throughout the year.
Which would be the case
in quite a large part
of the Mediterranean area,
big part of Asia, for example.
In a lot of warmer
climates in the world,
you wouldn't really
have any incentive
to store foods, at least not
for a longer period of time.
And the interesting
thing with all
of these marginal climates--
doesn't really matter where
you are in the world--
they have two product
groups in common
that have been huge in
historical importance
and essentially things
that made people lived
through the harsh winters.
And those two product groups,
they are grains and dairy.
And both grains and dairy,
they are not only high energy,
but they're also very easily
produced in large quantities
during fairly cool summers.
And on top of that,
both grains and dairy,
they are easily
prepared for storage.
With dairy, you can think
cultured dairy products--
butter, cheese--
all things that
keep really well.
And all things that are
very dense in energy,
so they don't take up
a lot of storage space
when you keep them.
For the cereals, all
seeds of perennial grasses
make great storage crop.
They dry well, they
store well, and they
can be turned into a
lot of different things.
And it doesn't matter, if
you're in the Peruvian Andes,
if you're in a monastery
in Bhutan in the Himalayas,
or if you're in a suburb of
Ostersund, where I grew up.
It doesn't matter if it's
corn or red rice or wheat.
Or if it's milk from
a llama or yak or cow.
The same sort of
basic principles
apply over all of these
marginal climates.
And I think that baking--
which I thought was
going to be very
easy to define what baking is.
It turns out that it's
not easy to define at all.
And I think that
baking is simply
like a catchall phrase
for all of the ways
that humankind can turn grains
sometimes in combination
with dairy into food.
How we can turn these two basic
product groups into something
that's more easily digestible,
more tasty, and more
varied than the products
are on their own.
And I think that the fact
that we've created so much
variation with such a limited
number of base products
as we have in baking
compared to savory food.
Just imagine.
Almost all baking recipes, they
contain the same five things
in different variations.
And if you look at
the savory cooking,
you have thousands of
different base products
that becomes various
combinations.
And I think that this
great diversity in number
of recipes and
expressions in baking,
it really says a lot
about how important
and how big a part of our
daily caloric intake that used
to come from grains and dairy.
We were really, really motivated
to create a lot of diversity
in recipes.
Today, we often tell
ourselves that we decide
what we eat all the time.
That no one else dictates
what products we buy
and what we make from them.
From my perspective, this is
obviously completely wrong.
Because we are animals.
We do exactly what our
species has always done.
We procure whatever products
that make sense to us
there and then.
And we prepare them in whatever
way that makes sense to us
there and then.
And then we eat them
ourselves or with our flock.
That's what we do.
And the thing though that
fascinates me so much with
this-- especially when
it comes to baking--
it's the amount of
cultural knowledge
that's transmitted
between generations.
Because eating correctly
grown, preserved, stored,
and subsequently prepared foods
made from grains and dairy,
it used to be incredibly
important for our ancestors.
For them, it was
simply about survival,
which is the single strongest
motivating force of the human
being.
Today, for almost all of
us, eating breads and cakes
and buns and cookies or
whatever else we've baked,
it's mostly about pleasure.
And why do we find
it so pleasurable?
And the easy explanation
here is that these items are
dense in energy and that we
are predisposed to like things
that are dense in energy.
And that might explain why
we find a piece of cookie
very tasty.
But it doesn't explain why
we're so motivated to pass
on this cultural information
between generations
and why it's so
pleasurable to bake.
And I think that's simply our--
humankind's-- function
put in place by humankind
in our subconscious minds to
make sure that we don't lose
this information just because
there's a new generation
coming.
Almost everyone I know
take more pleasure
and they feel more
satisfied when
they've baked something than
when they've cooked something
savory.
Personally, I'm more happy when
I bake a sponge cake than when
I make an oven omelet.
And I think this is just
a really good indicator
on how our minds function.
And this sort of boils
down to my final big reason
to why the Nordic baking culture
truly is the greatest around.
Preparing all of these
grains and dairy products,
well, it used to be
more important where
I come from than in almost
any other part of the world.
And I think this is
also the reason why
most people in the Nordics
still bake more in their homes
than people do in other
parts of the world.
We just take more
pleasure in it,
because it used to be more
important for us in the past.
And as with all culture, if
culture is regularly practiced
on an everyday basis, if culture
is allowed to change gradually
because of use, it will always
be more diverse and deeply
rooted than if it's carried
out by just a few people
or kept in tact in a bubble.
And I think this is the final
reason from my side to why
the Nordic baking
culture is just
the most diverse baking
culture on the planet today.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
And now we can do questions.
Do we have a mic or yeah.
Cool.
And it can be
questions about this,
about the project
with these books.
It can be questions about
Faviken and my restaurant.
anything you want really.
So raise some hands.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
that during the process
for researching this entire
project that you thought
at the beginning you knew a
lot about certain Nordic food
culture and Nordic
baking culture,
but you found that you knew
a lot less than you did.
What are some examples of some
particularly interesting things
that you learned?
MAGNUS NILSSON: For me,
the most interesting
I learned was actually how much
diversity there is out there.
Because, first of all,
there's no such thing
as a common Nordic identity.
I don't know.
There are some Nordic
people here for sure.
There might be more,
but I think all
of us living in
the Nordic region,
we feel a strong identity
connected to where we're from.
But that's usually not like,
hey, I'm Nordic, you know?
I'm Swedish.
And I think that because
of this, we might not
have been receptive to
our neighboring cultures
as much as we should have.
At least that applies to me.
I guess traveling around,
meeting people in their homes,
talking about food, seeing what
they actually cook and bake
on an everyday
basis, it's just been
eye opening how much difference
in cultural diversity
is out there.
AUDIENCE: What's the difference
in bread between hand kneading
it and using a KitchenAid?
MAGNUS NILSSON: The
KitchenAid specifically, it's
one way of machine kneading.
But it has a
specific expression,
because of the size of the
bowl and the way it moves.
But I think that if we just
look at machine processed versus
hand processed, theoretically,
there has to be no difference.
Doesn't have to
be any difference.
Because the dough doesn't
know what's going on to it.
And there is a lot
of different machines
that can take care of this.
And this is something
that I've spoken
to a lot of bakers about.
And very begrudgingly,
most of them
agree that a machine should
be able to do exactly
as well as a human being.
But then there are other
parts of the baking process
that machines, at
least not yet, are
able to replicate perfectly.
AUDIENCE: In your
research, did you
find any regional difference
between the different grains
depending on where
they're grown?
I'm thinking about all the
different kinds of wheats
there are.
What about different
kinds of rye,
for instance, different corn
coming from different parts.
Or is it all just so
mixed in the processing
we don't really know?
MAGNUS NILSSON: The thing is
that, if you look further back,
there was more
regional diversity.
When farmers would take
and produce their own seed
from their crop and then
reseed that next year,
you would have a larger
degree of genetic diversity
in whatever was produced
in various regions.
Not just grains.
But today-- for the
last 100 plus years--
pretty much all of
the commercial growers
of [INAUDIBLE] crops use the
same handful of varieties.
And in this book, it's about--
this documentary [INAUDIBLE]
about what people
bake today at home.
Meaning that most
of the research
has also been into what people
use at home, which is largely
the same types of flour.
AUDIENCE: I just
thought it would
be interesting to have
terroir of difference.
MAGNUS NILSSON: It will be
very interesting to have
terroir of different grains,
but it's actually nonexistent.
[LAUGHS]
We buy, for example,
to Faviken, we
buy specific varieties
of various grains
from specific farms,
and we use that.
But that's a very extreme
expression of baking.
That's not at all
representative of what
people bake in the home.
And I think that we
will most likely never
have that type of
variety in the home just
for practical reasons.
And then whether that's
sad or whether it's
efficient and good, I
mean, that's up to anyone.
And for me, a big part
of making this book
has also been to
remove my opinions
from the content matter, which
is not easy all the time.
Because when you run a
restaurant like Faviken,
and it's all about pushing
your agenda and your opinion
and showcasing that in the food.
But for it to be documentary and
representative for the region,
I had to remove that.
AUDIENCE: What do you consider
a therapeutic dish to make?
MAGNUS NILSSON:
Therapeutic dish to make.
I think that the
pretty much all baking
can be fairly therapeutic.
I like making chocolate oatmeal
balls, which is essentially
butter, and sugar, and
oatmeal, and cocoa powder.
And very rarely does it ever
make it to the ball stage.
Usually, it sort of just
disappears meanwhile.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned earlier
talking about the fresh yeast.
I've definitely found
it very frustrating
following Nordic recipes
because the expectations
of a convention oven and
fresh yeast and [INAUDIBLE]..
You mentioned that you did
some testing in America.
What changes did you
find that you had to make
or how did you acknowledge
these differences in your books?
MAGNUS NILSSON: Yeah.
So it's actually, it's
a bit complicated.
Because as I said, it's
a documentary book,
and none of the recipes
have been adapted in any way
not to better fit
specific territories.
Or even if I've seen a lot
of recipes where I'm like,
I can do that so much better
if I change it a little bit.
But I haven't done that.
And the same thing goes here.
So what I've done,
though, is that I've
written narrative text,
and I provided information
on some of these topics.
Like I've written how yeast
functions, for example,
and what the differences would
be between fresh and dry yeast.
And I've explained a little
bit in how to substitute
and how to work with that.
I've written about the
variation in different flours,
because there's a huge
difference in flours
across the world, not
just between America
and other parts, but everywhere.
And even within the US,
there's a big difference
in how flour behaves.
And then there is
also other recipes.
What to do if you
don't have a giant wood
fired brick oven, for
example, when you make
flatbreads and stuff like that.
But it is documentary.
And the recipes, as
such, they are exactly
as they are in
the Nordic region.
AUDIENCE: I'm really
curious to hear more
about the interaction of
identity and nationality.
Do you think it's the
case that there hasn't
been this identity
of a food culture,
because there's so much
regional diversity?
And then also, on
the other side,
your books are branding
this idea of Nordic cuisine.
Do you think there is a
broader Nordic identity
that even though the national
identity that is emerging
or that you would like to see?
MAGNUS NILSSON: I think
it has always been there.
It's just that us
living there, we
don't like to acknowledge it,
because we feel more strongly
for our specific
national identity rather
than a common Nordic one.
And the Nordic region,
it's a geographical region.
It's not a cultural region.
But there are a lot of
things that bind us together
culturally as well.
But there are equally many
things that tear us apart.
And one interesting
thing that you
can see when it comes
to the way people
used to cook and
still cooks today--
and bake as well,
for that matter--
is that at the base, you have
these climatic and geographical
differences.
That's a constant.
That's just there.
And then on top of that, you
have a cultural layer as well,
like a little
cultural filter that
informs what people do
with these geographical
circumstances.
And most of that, I
would say, it actually
depends on who occupied
whom in the past.
Which is sort of strange and
a bit interesting and funny.
But you can divide
the Nordic region
into two cultural regions--
one that's Swedish influenced.
And that's like from
Sweden and then Finland
and around the Baltics.
All the Baltic
countries and Poland,
they're not part of
the Nordics anymore.
But they have a very
distinctive Swedish influence
on that cultural layer
on top of the geography.
And then the western
bit would have the same
with Danish influence.
And it really shows.
Because in that cultural
region, for example,
you have Greenland, the
Faroe Islands, and Iceland.
Greenland and Faroe Islands
are still part of Denmark.
Iceland was occupied by
Denmark for many, many years.
None of these islands would
have ever seen any grain
before the Danes came.
Because the climate doesn't
really support growing grains,
and they're just so isolated.
But today, they have
a bread culture.
And you can trace
almost all of it
back to the Danish
cultural influence.
All of these countries, they
would have their own version
of, for example, the very
iconic Danish rye bread,
but made to suit
their circumstances.
On Iceland, for
example, the country
that has almost no trees,
the source of energy
to heat the home
was traditionally
peat moss that was
dug out of a peat bog,
and lugged home, and
dried, and then burnt.
And obviously, a very laborious
process to create fuel.
Meaning that people
weren't exactly inclined
to fire up a giant brick
oven to bake a loaf of bread.
So before the Danes
came there, they
didn't really have any
type of baked goods at all.
With the Danes came
people from Denmark
who obviously lived on Iceland,
because it was occupied,
managing everything.
They wanted their bread.
And Iceland has a lot
of volcanic activity.
So what people did
instead was just
dig holes in the ground
outside of the villages
and lower a bucket of rye
bread down into the hole,
come back the day
after in the morning,
and pick up a loaf
of steamed bread.
And that still goes on today.
And it is very easy to think,
when you're in Iceland,
oh, they've been doing
this for a thousand years.
But they haven't.
They've been doing it
for 200 years, which
is not very long in a
historical perspective.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
What is your favorite
recipe in this book?
MAGNUS NILSSON: As I
said before, it's been--
most the process has been
about me not imposing
too much of my opinion
on the content matter.
And the choice of recipes, it's
entirely independent on what
I think is good and bad.
It's about what represents
the most people in the region
and the most parts of the
regions as well as possible.
But then naturally,
there are recipes that--
for various reasons--
I personally feel more for.
And that will probably
be things that
has to do with my childhood
like soft Swedish flatbreads,
for example.
The chocolate balls
I mentioned earlier.
And then things I didn't know
existed like the Icelandic rye
bread is also, to
me, very appealing.
Even if I've never
baked it myself,
just the fact that it exists.
AUDIENCE: I have a
question about flours,
and if you just had a
recommendation for resources
for the non-professional or the
non-culinary school educated
person.
I love baking.
And historically, I've
always been interested
in alternative flours, and
now I'm really interested
more in wheat flours.
But just the variations of
wheat flours and understanding
the protein content and
how they all interact
and what brands to buy.
Simple things like that.
I find myself traveling to
a million different places
on the internet and
Googling things.
And I don't know what's right.
And I'm just wondering if
there's a central resource
that you would tell
somebody to go to,
this is a good
education on flour.
MAGNUS NILSSON: I don't
have one specific one
that's available here.
And what I do know is that there
is a huge amount of difference.
Not just in what grains
that are used to make flour,
but also in the
various processes used.
How things are milled,
how things are aged,
how they are
transported, and so on.
And it all affects how
they bake in the end.
So I think that the only
thing that I can suggest
is try buying a flour
that seems to be good.
Because there are
many other reasons
than just pure functionality.
Might be that it's organic.
That it's milled close to
where you live, whatever.
Buy that and then use only that
until you learn how it behaves.
And then you'll be able to
adapt recipes into that.
It's very hard to be
general about these things,
because they differ so much.
And there are no--
I haven't found any
great books on this.
There's lots of research papers.
You can go into
university search engines,
and you can look for things and
read people's crappy abstracts
about wheat kernels
and things like that.
And it is very interesting.
But maybe someone
should write that book.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
You just defined earlier
baking as the transformation
of grains.
And my family is of
Norwegian origination
though we've been
here for awhile.
[INAUDIBLE],, lefse,
which is from potato.
MAGNUS NILSSON: But never
[? yes ?] to potato, right?
AUDIENCE: What?
MAGNUS NILSSON: Never
[? yes ?] potato.
AUDIENCE: Right.
Does that fit in
your definition?
MAGNUS NILSSON: It does.
AUDIENCE: And can you
tell me anything--
I don't know anything about it.
MAGNUS NILSSON: So lefse is
the traditional Norwegian
flatbread.
And the big difference
between lefse
and most of the other
flatbreads in the Nordic region
is that they are griddled.
They're not baked in an oven.
And they also use other--
it's not just flour
base, as you say.
Quite a few of them
have potato in them.
A lot of them have peas in them
as well and things like that.
And the reason why
they're not oven baked
is that most of Norway, it's a
bit like Iceland in the sense
that there are not any
large, deep forests.
Most of the country.
And that's compared to
Sweden, for example,
where the generation of my
grand-grandparents, they
all had 1,000 hectares
of pine forest
that was pretty much worthless.
All that was good
for was firewood.
So they had a lot of that.
And therefore, we
have a tradition
of these great big brick ovens.
On every farm, there
is one of those.
So all of our flatbreads
are baked in that.
Norway, they didn't have
access to fuel in that way,
so they had to be
more energy efficient.
And a little fire
under a griddle.
It's a much more efficient
way of baking flatbreads.
So I think, yeah.
AUDIENCE: In your
research, you try to,
like you said, not alter
any of these recipes.
Are there any recipes or
breads made in very far
off regions that you're worried
about [INAUDIBLE] die out
or anything that you want
to do to preserve them?
MAGNUS NILSSON: So
this is also something
that I realized
during this process.
And before this, I think that
I was more on the opinion
that traditional food
culture is very important
to preserve as it is.
And I've come to realize more
and more that it's actually--
that's completely wrong.
Because food culture has
to be allowed to evolve,
and we will always
eat what makes sense
to us, wherever we
are, whoever we are,
and whatever time it will be.
What's important, though, is
to preserve the knowledge.
To make sure that food
culture is properly
and accurately documented.
Because it's a
waste of knowledge
if it just stops being
practiced and then everyone else
forgets about it.
It might have taken generations
or thousands of years
of empirical study
and living to come up
with a lot of these techniques.
And this is a hard
thing actually,
because almost everyone doesn't
quite agree with me on this.
Almost everyone, I think,
often without thinking,
just assess that
these traditions
are so important to keep alive.
But who's going to
keep them alive?
In Sweden, we have sour
herring, for example--
the stinkiest food
on planet Earth.
And I think that
wait 30 more years,
and it's going to be gone.
And I'm not going to be
sorry that it is gone.
But I would be very sorry if
the knowledge on how to make it
would disappear, yes, because
we don't eat it anymore.
AUDIENCE: I'm also from Sweden.
MAGNUS NILSSON: Hello.
AUDIENCE: It seems
to me what you
said about baking applies to
a lot of other foods as well.
So my experience is a lot of us
eat home cooked food every day.
And I haven't seen that to the
same extent in other places
that I've been [INAUDIBLE].
First of all, do you think
that's true, and [INAUDIBLE]..
MAGNUS NILSSON: I think,
yeah, I think it's
absolutely true even today.
The development in
the Nordic region,
especially in the bigger
cities, is that people
eat more and more out.
It becomes more and more like
other parts of the world.
But we still eat a
bigger part of our meals
in the home cooked by
ourselves than almost
any other Western culture does.
And I think it has to
do with historically
a lot of different reasons.
One of them being scarcity
of population, that just not
enough people in a
large part of the region
to sustain restaurants.
And then I think that
there are cultural factors
on top of that as
well us religion,
for example, and
many other things.
But what I do know,
though, is that this
is one of the reasons why Nordic
food culture and baking culture
is so little understood.
Because it's inaccessible.
Not just the way I
spoke about before
with recorded information.
But also the practical
act of eating Nordic food.
If you go to Sweden, for
example, as a tourist.
You go to Stockholm
and think to yourself
that I'm going to have one
traditional Swedish meal when
I'm here.
You're not going to get that.
There's not a single
restaurant in Stockholm
that produces something
that is remotely
close to an authentic version of
what people eat in their homes.
Because that's not
what restaurants
are about in that region.
And that differs a lot from
central and southern Europe,
for example.
It's very easy to go to
Spain and go to a restaurant
and find something that's
definitely a bit adapted
to the world of restaurants,
but that fairly accurately
represents the same thing
as you would cook at home.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
The other question also is there
a tradition of high altitude
baking in the region?
MAGNUS NILSSON: We don't
have that much high altitude
in the Nordic region.
And where we have
a bit of altitude--
in Sweden, the tallest mountains
are like 1,500 or so meters.
And no one lives there.
Traditionally, no
one lived up there.
It's like where I'm from--
which is considered quite high
in altitude-- is 350 meters.
So I don't have a
specific knowledge of it.
I know that we had some
feedback from recipe testers
in Mexico City, for example,
that a lot of the recipes
behave very differently.
Thank you guys for coming today.
And thanks for having me again.
[APPLAUSE]